You know I love Bethany. We're good friends.
But she really pushed your- Really?
And you pushed- She's your good friend?
She is. We talk more than you and me on the
phone. What? Oh.
Oh, no. You're.
Now you just suck yourself, b*tch.
But I never go visit her!
You talk with Bethany?
All the time she texts me.
And you texted back.
I call bullsh*t. You said you have more
communication with Bethany than you do with
Luann. That's hurtful.
How do you think that makes me feel?
Cut, cut cut, cut.
And I will explain that. Sonia,
that's hurtful after the conversation
yesterday. No, I
suck, I'm the worst friend ever, you know?
But when I'm back, just text back.
We just missed you, Sonia.
That's okay. You guys are my best friends.
I don't have to answer you.
What? What is she saying?
You know, it's insulting because we are
actually Sonia's friends, and now she's
prioritizing this other person.
It's like. Really?
Then your priorities are all wrong.
If you
don't understand. I'm a friend and you don't
understand. I'm a friend and you don't
understand. With you, we never said get it?
Go this way. So let's ask.
I don't want you to be upset.
It's not that important.
You know. I choose my private time with you.
You know that. My vacations and private
time. Do you see me on Instagram?
I've seen you for three years.
And who has seen me? Do you see me going out
with other girls? Do you see me going to
lunch or shopping? Do you?
Do you. No we don't.
Okay, I'm telling you, I'm not with other
people. It's not that I don't want to be
with them, but it makes me feel bad because
they're not understanding.
When I'm not with them. I'm working or,
like, looking for a place to live.
These girls are like, you know, jet setting.
I'm bouncing from couch to couch with family
. Sonja let's move on. I don't want to do
this. I had a very good talk with-.
Let's change the subject.
Let's change it. Kelly and I had a good talk.
Let's change it to that, and I apologize.
Change it. I don't want you upset.
I'm not upset.
Listen, you set me off.
You said something about.
Okay? I'm sorry. How less important I am.
And it made me feel like.
Her feelings are hurt.
If I text
Sonja on a
Monday, I don't hear from her for two weeks.
She may eventually call back.
And for a lot of the girls, it's sort of
like a little bit of a slap in the face
because we've been rooting for Sonja and
having her back for a long time now.
Can we go back to Sonja's first question
about what happened?
What triggered you?
Because I
know you before the show.
And I knew you during the show, and you were
a different person. And I know that you were
triggered by something.
And you triggered Bethany because she came
for you. You are the
most unintelligent human being I've ever had
the pleasure to be around. No, no.
Yeah. Really? Yeah.
She went after me. Yeah.
And so she could say that she was the victim
of a craziness that I have.
I mean, anyone that knows me, I'm.
I'm so normal.
I've had nightmares for the last week about
her stabbing me.
Like, I'm like.
And even tempered.
You need a
freaking timeout, okay?
I don't want a time out. I want you to zip
it. I was down before, and so she was like,
in a take down the socialite.
What a nut
bag.
Does anyone want a jelly bean?
Just calm down and look.
You're absolutely crazy, okay?
I'm crazy. It's all like a joke.
I wouldn't have done anything to get off
that island. And I told you that the next
day. I just didn't understand
what trigger you. You got, like, what
triggered you? Because you're, like,
completely normal every time I see you.
I've never even related you to that.
Because she's not. That's what
I mean. So for you, she's not crazy.
They made her crazy.
She doesn't want to admit she'll had a
meltdown. I think, out of respect for her.
Okay, I think we just drop the subject.
I've seen her a thousand times since then.
And I never once even heard about
it. Right.
You know, I like Kelly.
So far. I haven't watched Scary Island yet,
but I always try to go into all situations
with an open mind. I think Kelly at this
point is
quirky. To be coined this name, "Crazy Kelly"
. When I am so far from that I mean crazy
hot.
Can't help that.
So when I see Kelly out.
She's always.
Very confident in control.
And then she said, you know, I'm actually
not very confident, ladies.
I have a secret as insecure.
We think we are as women.
Men are more insecure.
You think so? Oh, absolutely.
It's a fact.
Is it a secret? It's a tip.
It's a tip.